WHAT THE PEACHES I DO WHEN AND
WHERE THEY'RE FROM AND HOW YOU
GROW ON. THEY WERE THERE AN
ORCHARD IN EVERY YEAR. EXCEPT
FOR ONE YEAR BECAUSE THE BREAK
WAS TOO LONG AND TOO HOT AND
THE PEACHES ROVER RIGHT SO WE
THEY PICKED UP OFF THE TREE.
THE DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY SO
THEY'RE VERY RIPE AND READY TO
EAT I'VE FIFTY LUGS. IN THE
BASEMENT SO MEMBERS FROM TEN TO
TEN THIRTY AND THEN ALL THE
BUILDING AFTER THAT SO YOU
BETTER SHOW PARTY BECAUSE THEY
GO FAST. AND I EXPECTED. PEACH
COBBLER IN MY OFFICE AND FROM
SIDE. NO ANYWAY WHICH ENJOY
THEY'RE REALLY NICE. REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THANK YOU
MAY HAVE WITH THAT PUBLIC
SERVICE NOW SO WE CAN. FORUM.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND THE SUBSEQUENT. SENATOR
ALLEN HERE. TOWN PRESENT
SENATOR BATES SENATE OLLIE.
SENATOR HILL. SENATOR SKINNER.
SENATOR STERN SENATOR BY CASKEY
OKAY SO WE HAVE A QUORUM
ESTABLISH WE ALSO HAVE OUR
AUTHOR HERE WE APPRECIATE YOU.
AND WILL NEXT YEAR FROM THE
SERVER RACEMATE COME UP AND
PERCENT AJ ARE TEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE. FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS RESOLUTION I
LOOK FORWARD TO COORDINATING
WITH STAFF TO UPDATE THIS
RESOLUTION DURING THE NEXT
PHASE OF THE PROCESS. EIJI ARE
TEN MAKES CLEAR CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP IN THE FIGHT FOR
CLEAN AIR BY STATING THE
LEGISLATURE'S STRONG AND
UNEQUIVOCAL SUPPORT OF THE
STATE'S AUTHORITY TO ENACT
STRICTER AIR POLLUTION
STANDARDS. STANDARDS PURSUANT
TO ITS WAIVER UNDER THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT IN ADDITION AS IT
WILL BE AMENDED THIS RESOLUTION
ARTICULATES THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT. FOR A RECENT AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE STATE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND AUTOMOBILE
MANUFACTURERS WHICH WILL AND
CONTINUE TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA
LEADS ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC
ADMINISTRATION AND THE U. S.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
AGENCY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN PROPOSED UNDER THE
PRESENT ADMINISTRATION THE SAY
FOR AFFORDABLE FUEL EFFICIENT
OR THE SO CALLED SAFE VEHICLE
ROOM THIS PROPOSAL AIM TO TAKE
ACTION THAT WOULD WEAKEN THE
ABILITY OF CALIFORNIA TO ENACT
ENACT POLICIES THAT ADDRESS
PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES AND TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL AIMS TO END CURRENT
FUEL ECONOMY TARGETS IN TWENTY
TWENTY AND TAKE AWAY
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO SET OUR
OWN MORE STRINGENT VEHICLE
STANDARDS. THIS ROOM MADE CLEAR
THAT THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WAS COMMITTED TO EMBARKING ON A
POORLY CRAFTED TO STRATEGY TO
ROLL BACK THE PROGRESS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE ON CLEANER.
DESPITE THE SUPPOSEDLY BENEFIT
TO THE PROPOSAL THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ADOPTING THE
ADMINISTRATION STANDARD WILL BE
DETRIMENTAL IT IS ESTIMATED
THAT IT WOULD NOT ONLY INCREASE
OIL CONSUMPTION BY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND BARRELS PER DAY BUT IT
IS ESTIMATED TO COST CALIFORNIA
THIRTY SIX BILLION DOLLARS. DUE
TO NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY. THE SITUATION LED THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO NEGOTIATE DIRECTLY WITH THE
VEHICLE MANUFACTURERS
REPRESENTING APPROXIMATELY 30%
OF NEW CARS AND SUVS SOLD IN
THE UNITED STATES. ON JULY
TWENTY FOURTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AN AGREEMENT WAS
ANNOUNCED. REGARDING EMISSION
STANDARDS INCENTIVES TO ADOPT A
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATIONS AND
DECREASES IN MANUFACTURES AND
CRUDE COST PENALTIES BY
EXTENDING PRODUCTION DEADLINES.
THIS AGREEMENT APPLAUDED BY
MANY IS A PRIME EXAMPLE OF
REGULATORS AND INDUSTRY WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS AIR
POLLUTION EVEN IN THE FACE OF A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LOOKING TO
OBSTRUCT PROGRESS. CALIFORNIA
MUST CLEARLY STATE THAT WE
STRONGLY AND UNEQUIVOCALLY
SUPPORT CLEAN AIR AND REJECT
ANY MEASURE THAT ROLLS BACK
PROGRESS OF AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS WE MUST CONTINUE OUR
ROLE AS A NATIONAL LEADER. IN
EGGS IN ACTING MEASURES TO
PROGRESS TO PROGRESS
LONGSTANDING PROTECTIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS PUBLIC HEALTH THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMIC
VITALITY. HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION ARE ROCKY
RUSHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
MELISSA FROM METAL WITH A
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. ROCKY
RUSHING WITH KHALIF CLEAN AIR
MR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CLIMATE CHANGE IS THE
FOUNDATIONAL CHALLENGE FACED BY
CALIFORNIA IN THE REST OF THE
NATION. LAST WEEK THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
ANNOUNCED A ONE PERCENT
DECREASE IN THE STATE'S GHG
EMISSIONS. FIND MUCH WILL
HOWEVER IF THAT'S THE RIGHT
RIGHT PHRASE IT REMAINS THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WHERE
MISSIONS WERE UP NEARLY 1% DUE
IN LARGE PART TO PASSENGER
VEHICLES. IN ADDITION TO OUR
PLANET HEATING UP IN THE
RESULTING WILDFIRES EXTREME
WEATHER PATTERNS AND ECONOMIC
AND ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
OUR BREATHING POLLUTED AIR
THAT'S MAKING THEM SICK. THIS
IS A BACKDROP THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS PUSHING TO
FREEZE EXISTING FUEL ECONOMY IN
GHG EMISSIONS STANDARDS THAT
WOULD ILLUSTRATE GROWING BLOW
TO OUR NATION'S ECONOMIC
CLIMATE GOALS. DAVID MS IN
MINISTRATIONS ALSO ATTEMPTED TO
STRIP CALIFORNIA OF ITS THIRTY
TO SET ITS OWN EMISSIONS
STANDARDS UNDER THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT. WHICH THIRTEEN
STATES PLUS WASHINGTON DC HAVE
ALSO ADOPTED. LITIGATION WOULD
CERTAINLY FOLLOW MAKING
ECONOMIC ANIMATIONS OUTCOMES
AND CLEAR S WELL AS SPLIT IN
THE NATION'S. VEHICLE MARKET
BECAUSE IN A REGULATORY AND
FINANCIAL HEADACHE FOR AUTO
MAKERS. CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
ABOUT 12% OF THE NATION'S AUTO
MARKET BY THE WAY. FORBES
RECENTLY REPORTED THAT IF
SUCCESSFUL TRUMP'S CLEAN CAR
ROLL BACK WILL COST US
CONSUMERS UP TO FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS THROUGH TWENTY
FIFTY AND INCREASE
TRANSPORTATION EMISSIONS 10% IN
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. FOR THESE
REASONS AND MORE CAL KALIEF
CLEANER SUPPORTS AJ ARE CAN AND
THANKS ASSEMBLYMEMBER RADIUS
FOR ITS INTRODUCTION A JAR CAN
SEND A CLEAR AND UNMISTAKABLE
STATEMENT THAT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WILL NOT
WAVER OR RETREAT FROM OUR
THIRTY TO SET EMISSION
STANDARDS. THAT GO BEYOND THOSE
SET BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
YOU AMENDMENTS TO THE
RESOLUTION IS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED WILL ALIGN IT
WITH RECENT PACT BETWEEN CARBON
FOR OTHER AUTOMAKERS. DOUBLE
CIRCUMVENT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ESTABLISH
VOLUNTARY EMISSION STANDARDS
AND THE NEW YORK TIMES WAS
REPORTING YESTERDAY THAT
MERCEDES BENZ WILL BE JOINING
THE PACK AS WELL SO THAT'S A
STRONG STATEMENT. THREE DECADES
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A NATIONAL
LEADER IN ESTABLISHING
BENCHMARK FOR AUTOMATION'S WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S AT STAKE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN CAR
STANDARDS HAVE RESULTED IN
PASSENGER VEHICLES THAT
POLLUTED LESS WHILE SAVING
CONSUMERS MONEY AT THE PUMP AND
REDUCING HEALTHCARE COSTS. AND
THOUGH CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR CONTINUES
TO PRODUCE ABOUT 37% OF THE
STATE'S GHG EMISSIONS CARR
REPORTS THAT THOSE LEVELS ARE
TAPERING OFF. SO NOW IS EXACTLY
THE RIGHT TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE A STRONG
STATEMENT STRONG ENOUGH TO BE
HEARD IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
COLLEGE CLEANER ASK THAT YOU
VOTE I ON AJ ARE TEN THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU ROCKY THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS. AS THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES
ITS IRRESPONSIBLE ATTACKS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE HEALTH OF
OUR PLANET CALIFORNIA HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEAD THE
NATION TO A MORE JUST AND
HEALTHY FUTURE. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR CONTINUES
TO BE THE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR
TO THE STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND WE MUST CONTINUE
TO PUSH FORWARD AND MAKE
PROGRESS ON FUEL EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS. AFTER THE NEWS THAT
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PLAN
TO SEVERELY ROLL BACK EXISTING
ROLES WHICH WOULD LIMIT THE
FUEL EFFICIENCY STANDARDS.
CALIFORNIA STEPPED UP AND
RESPONDED. THIS AGREEMENT MADE
BETWEEN AIR BEING AUTOMAKERS UP
HOLD PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WHILE ALSO.
GROWING OUR ECONOMY AND SAVING
CONSUMERS MONEY AT THE PUMP. AJ
ARE TEN MAKES IT CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTS HIS ACTIONS
AND SUPPORTS ENHANCEMENTS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. PROTECTIONS AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
YOUR. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M NOT THE ONLY
A GARCIA I AM A LEVERAGE FELLOW
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISES
OFFICE VERY FORTUNATE TO BE
HERE AND I HAVE HELPED HER A
WITH THE DRAFT AMENDMENTS TO
THAT WILL BE COMING UP AS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS CONTINUES
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I.
AM MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER
EXCELLENT. ANOTHER GREAT
EXAMPLE ARE WONDERFUL FELLOWS
PROGRAMS THANK YOU I YES GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS COREY
BULLIS ON BEHALF OF CAL START
VALLEY CLEANER NOW BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS AND
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AS CHAIR MEMBERS APOLOGY A ONE
THINKING ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
ON BEHALF OF TESLA AND BOMB
BEHALF OF TESLA IN FULL SUPPORT
OF WE'VE BEEN. WHAT WHAT
FIGHTING THE PROBLEMS IN
WASHINGTON DC FROM DAY ONE SAM
NICE TO SEE OTHER CAR
MANUFACTURERS ARE JOINING IN.
THANK YOU. HI GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS JOANNA MINE I'M ALSO
LOVE RICH FOLLOW BUT WITH THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION AND
WE DEFINITELY WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE AG ARE TEN. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS. HI ALEX
LEWIS CHARGE WHEN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OKAY I
ANYONE ONE SERIOUS CONCERNS ARE
OPPOSITION THE BILL. OKAY THE
ITEMS NOW BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS SENATE OLLIE.
THANK YOU SO YESTERDAY I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. THE WITH
THE GOVERNOR IN LAKE TAHOE AND
SENATOR FEINSTEIN IN THE
GOVERNOR FROM NEVADA AS TO THE
GOVERNOR ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT.
THAT THERE HAS BEEN IS THE
BASICALLY THE CAR MANUFACTURERS
HAVE AGREED TO JUST DO IT
WITHOUT. THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING
IT ON THEIR OWN RIGHT THERE
THERE WOULD BE WITHOUT THE
REGULATION OF THE IF OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CRACKED. SO
THEY ARE ENTERING INTO THE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA YOUR RIGHT TO DO IT.
DIRECTLY AND USING THE STATE ON
THEIR OWN SO IT'S A BUSINESS
DECISION TO. GET A HIGHER
MILEAGE. THEY HAVE THEIR
FLEETS. RAISE THE MILEAGE
STANDARD IS IN THERE SO THEIR
DINNER ON THERE SO WHAT'S SO
WHAT'S SO WHY WOULD THERE BE A
NEED FOR AND AJ ARE IF THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING IT ON THEIR OWN.
SOME OF THE IT'S NOT ALL
MANUFACTURERS THAT ARE DOING
THIS BUT THERE HAVE BEEN
AGREEMENTS AND WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORTS IN THIS
REGARD HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
THIS. BUT I THINK THAT THE
STATEMENT HOUSE TO BE CLEAR
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO ACCEPT
LOWER STANDARDS. YES IT IS A
BUSINESS DECISION WE SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THAT. BUT CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS WILL FOREVER BE HIRED
THEM WHAT OTHER. WITH WITH THE.
THE FEDERAL GVERNMENT IS
REQUIRING WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN A
LEADER IN THIS SPACE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A LEADER. THOUGH
I APPRECIATE ON FIRST I'M-
DON'T HAVE A DOG IN THE FIGHT
AYE AYE I AM SUPER EXCITED
ABOUT GETTING VEHICLES TO GO
FURTHER ON A GALLON. FUEL CELL
I THINK EVERYBODY IS I THINK
THAT'S A LOT TO GO BUT I WILL
SHOW YOU YOUR DISTRICT. YEAH I
HAVE TO DRIVE A LOT. SO. I HAVE
TWO VEHICLES RIGHT NOW THAT OUR
PRIMARY VEHICLES THAT HAVE
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
MILES OF PEACE ON BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE TO DRIVE A LOT AND SO I'M
SUPER EXCITED ABOUT THE GOALS.
BUT I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU.
SOME OF THE FRUSTRATION THAT I
HAVE. WITH CALIFORNIA'S LEADING
IN. CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW IT
AFFECTS. SOMEBODY WAS IN
BUSINESS SO WE HAVE A TRUCKING
BUSINESS MY WIFE AND I AND WHEN
KEY CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD DECIDED TO MANDATE THAT
YOUR VEHICLE HAD TO BE
RETROFITTED NO MATTER. WHEN YOU
BOUGHT IT IT WAS. TO THE TO THE
LAWS THAT CALIFORNIA HAD SET.
AT THE TIME IT WAS MANUFACTURED
SO LET ME GIVE AN EXAMPLE IF
YOU HAVE A OF THE HEAVY VEHICLE
THAT'S DEBTS A TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO THOUSAND THIS IS PICK A
DATE TWO THOUSAND IT WAS
MANUFACTURED IN TWO THOUSAND TO
MEET THE STANDARDS OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN THE THEN
THE EPA THE FEDERAL EPA.
CALIFORNIA CAME IN AND SAID
WELL THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR
US WE NEED TO. MAKE YOU
RETROFIT YOUR VEHICLE AND SO IT
WAS ABOUT EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR RETROFITTED ONLY
CALIFORNIA DID. SO IN OUR CASE
WE AYE WE EACH HAVE TO RETROFIT
OR BY AND THEY GAVE US YOU GAVE
ME THEY GAVE ME SOME TIME. YOU
HAD HEALTH. IN CERTAIN CASES
TWENTY REDUCE OF THE IN MY
POINT IS THAT. WE KNEW THAT TO
THE PASSENGER CAR WE ONLY DID
IT TO THE PERSON WHO IS IN
BUSINESS IS TRACKING AND SO.
THE PASSENGER CAR IS ABLE TO AS
IT WEARS OUT THE MANUFACTURES
WERE MANDATED TO BRING US TO A
TEAR FOR MOTOR WHICH IS WHAT
THEY WE HAVE NOW AND SO YOU GOT
THE LIFE OF YOUR PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT. YOU GOT TO USE IT
AND YOU DIDN'T GET PUNISHED
CHANGING THE RULES IN THE
MIDDLE THE GAME AND SO MY POINT
IS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT HOW WE'RE CHANGES CLIMATE
AND WE WANT TO MAKE AIR CLEAN I
THINK WHAT WE'RE ALL FOR THAT I
DON'T KNOW ANYBODY THAT DOESN'T
WANT. A CLEAN ENVIRONMENT BUT
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE TO.
BUT JUST THE FACT THAT. YOU
CHANGE WHEN YOU CHANGE IT'S A
PENSIVE AND IT'S- AND IT'S ONLY
DAMAGING TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT AS YOU KNOW YOU'VE HEARD
ME SAY THIS. MANY TIMES AND MAY
THE MEMBERS IS THAT. YOU KNOW I
THINK OUR FOCUS ON THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. IS MAYBE
OR TO FOCUS TO AND LASER DOWN
ON TRANSPORTATION VERSES ALL
THE OTHER CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
THAT WE'RE- LIMITING OUT THERE
AND IN A I TALK ABOUT WILD FIRE
AND HOW MUCH. LOSE WE PUT OUT
IN WILD FIRE AND END OF A COST.
THAT WERE PUSHING DOWN ON THE
ON THE RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
WOULD BE HIGHLY OFFSET ABOUT
FOUR DOLLARS A TON TO DO FORCE
MANAGEMENT VERSES IN SOME CASES
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HIGH SPEED
TRAIN HUNDREDS TO A MILLION
DOLLARS A TON THAT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO ME SO FOR ME. I'M ALL
ABOUT. AIR BUT I WANT TO BRING
I WANNA ALLOW BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STAY HERE AND
THRIVE AND BE THE LEADER SO I
DID HEAR THE GOVERNOR SAY
YESTERDAY AND THAT YOU KNOW
WE'RE DOING AND OUR ECONOMY IS
RUNNING WILL. PARTS OF OUR
ECONOMY IS IN THE OTHER PARTS
ARE SUFFERING AND I I'M ON THE
SUFFERING INTO THAT. BECAUSE
WHEN YOU DO A BUSINESS PLAN AND
YOU. SAY I'M GONNA GO TO THE
BANK AND BORROW MONEY TO BUY
THIS PIECE OF EQUIPMENT TO. RUN
MY BUSINESS YOU HAVE TO PAY
THAT MONEY BACK AND THEN WHEN
THE GOVERNMENT COMES IN AND
CHANGES THE RULES IN THE MIDDLE
GAME THAT WASN'T PART OF YOUR
BUSINESS PLAN. THE GUY. AND THE
GUY IN OREGON. AND THE GUY IN
CHINA ARE. DOING THOSE SAME
THINGS THAT I HAVE TO DO AND
I'M COMPETING IT'S AND SO I
JUST WANT TO. MOVE IS NOT THIS
IS NOT DIRECTED TOWARDS. THE
AUTHOR THIS BILL I'M LOOKING AT
YOU BECAUSE IT YOUR BILL BUT I
WANT TO MAKE A STATEMENT HERE
BUT THAT WE NEED TO BE
CONSCIOUS OF THE FACT THAT. THE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE IN
CALIFORNIA. HER CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND ALSO. PUSHED UP
POLLUTION TO OTHER PLACES THAT.
DON'T DON'T HAVE THE SAME AS WE
WANT TO LEAD BUT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO LEAD. WITH WITH SOME.
ABILITY KEEP PEOPLE. DOING WHAT
THEY DO IN CALIFORNIA. SURE AND
THE SECONDLY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE REDUCE CARBON.
WHERE IT IS THE LEAST EXPENSIVE
AND I BELIEVE WE CAN DO THAT
THROUGH FORESTRY AND THROUGH
FIRE MITIGATION A LOT. LESS
EXPENSIVE THAN WE DO IN
TRANSPORTATION SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE THOSE IS NOT THIS IS
NOT DIRECTOR TO BUILD BUT IT'S
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. BECAUSE THERE IS
A LOT OF WE ALL TALK ABOUT
GOING ELECTRIC AND YET WE'RE
ALL FOR THAT BUT WE NEED TO DO
IT IN A IN A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO KEEP THIS ALSO. IN
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND YOU
KNOW ON TOP OF. A LOT OF OTHER
PIECES OF LEGISLATION IS NOT
JUST THE ONE. PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT CAUSE YOU TO.
HAVE PROBLEMS WE HAVE AB FIVE
NOW THIS IS IN MEAN WE HAVE A
LOT OF OTHER PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT MAKE IT VERY
DIFFICULT. TO BE IN BUSINESS
AND I HAPPEN TO KNOW PER FIRST
HERE BECAUSE IT IS. IT'S
ACTUALLY OUR BUSINESS THAT WE
DO SO. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE FALL FOR IT I'M ALL FOR
HIGH I WANT MY- DIESEL TRUCK TO
GET. THIRTY MILES AGAIN ON
SUNDAY THAT WOULD BE AWESOME.
I'M ALL FOR THAT. BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU.
THAT THE MEMBERS UNDER. AND
THAT THE ACTIONS WE TAKE YOUR
ARE PAINFUL AND THERE. AND IT
HURTS. YOUR BUSINESS WHEN YOU
HAVE A BUSINESS PLAN AND THE
GOVERNMENT CHANGE THE RULES.
AND NOT EVERYBODY IN THE
WORLD'S CHANGING THOSE RULES AS
WELL SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIRST OKAY YEAH. MR CHIRLA MOVE
THE MATTER. THANK YOU AS THE
CASKET ANY OTHER FURTHER
QUESTIONS THOUGHTS FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY I APPRECIATE. YOUR
COMMENTS SENATE ALI AND- YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE FOR THE CONVERSATION WE
SERVED TOGETHER ON SB NINE A
ONE OF THE COMMISSION AND SO
I'M VERY AWARE OF THE SENATORS
SENTIMENTS IN THIS REGARD I
THINK THAT WE ALL ARE LOOKING
FOR COMMON SENSE APPROACHES TO
THIS BUT I THINK WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH. WE
HAVE TO STEP IT UP AND I THINK
THAT THAT IS REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO HAVE THOSE PROTECTIONS WE
ALL WANT OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
TO THRIVE. ALL OF US I THINK
THERE WOULD BE ABSOLUTE
AGREEMENT. IN BOTH HOUSES BUT I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY US FOR
AN AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE MOVE BY CENTER CASKEY
SACRIFICE COLOR. AJ ARE TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES. AT THE
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED ALLEN HI
ALAN HI BATES. DOLLY HILL HILL
AYE SKINNER STERN. I CASKEY HI
MY CASKET HI OKAY SO WE WILL
HOLDER OPEN BE APPRECIATE THAT
AND. I'M ACTUALLY AT THE
PRESENT APPROPRIATIONS SO I'M
GONNA GO OVER THERE AND-
HOPEFULLY THE OTHER MEMBERS
WILL. COME SOON BUT FIVE. AND
CAN ONLY IMAGINE YOU'RE GONNA
THANK YOU VERY THAT WE'LL WE'LL
BRIEFLY RECESS AND NICE YOU I
MEAN I DON'T KNOW WHERE WHERE
THE SENATORS. SHE'S AND
PRESENTING. OKAY WHAT ARE. YEAH
DID YOU WANT ME TO STAY. I'LL
COME BACK LATER
. OKAY WHEN WE
RE OPEN THE ROLE TO ALLOW
CENTER SKINNER TO ADD ON THIS
IS FOR AJ ARE TEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AJ ARE
TEN BASE ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND VOTERS
THREE ZERO AT SKINNER. SKINNER
AYE STERN. OKAY THANK YOU. ON
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA RE OPEN THE
ROLE FRAZIER ARE TEND TO US IN
OUR STERN TO ADD ON SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM
NUMBER ONE AJ ARE TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES THE MOTION
IS BE ADOPTED STERN STERN AYE
OKAY OF THAT IS FIVE ZERO WITH
TWO ABSTENTIONS IN WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN THE JERRY TEN
AND DURING THIS HEARING OF. THE
SENATE. ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE